[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT: Jesse, who
is our guest, has
been working with Anji
Play in China, which
I think is a really
awesome new way of teaching
kids at an early childhood
just to be better people,
which I think is a good thing.
I'm not going to
steal his thunder,
so I'll let him go ahead and
tell you what it's all about.
[APPLAUSE]
JESSE COFFINO: Hi, everyone.
And thanks, Matt, for
that lovely introduction.
And it's really
quite an honor to be
at Google talking to
people that are part
of a revolutionary endeavor
to change how we think
and interact and what we do.
And so it's a really,
I think, fitting place
to talk about what's happening
in Anji, China, what's
starting to grow across
China, and what's
now coming to the United States
in the form of Anji Play.
And so Matt gave you a
brief introduction to me,
but I want to give you
some context about why
I'm the person here talking to
you, what my background is, how
I'm involved in this project.
About 3 and 1/2 years
ago, I get a phone call.
And it's from a
close friend, a woman
by the name of Dr. Chelsea
Bailey, former professor
of early education at
NYU, somebody with decades
of experience in the field.
And she says to me, Jesse,
I'm in Anji County, China.
There's a revolution
taking place.
I think she used the word
epistemological shift.
She said, the world
is going to change
because of the work that's
taking place right here, right
now.
You speak Chinese.
You read and write Chinese.
You're about to be a father.
You should stop
whatever you're doing,
and you should become a part
of what's happening right here.
And I am 100% certain
that in that moment,
my thought was, you're
out of your mind.
This is why I told you not
to drink the tap water.
You need to sleep more.
But I said, I don't know.
I'm a little bit busy.
She said, well, there's a
woman named Ms. Cheng Xueqin.
She is the force, the
mind, the drive behind
what's taking place.
And I'm bringing her
to the United States,
and she's going to
give some talks.
And I've got a
PowerPoint, and I need
you to translate that
PowerPoint for me.
It seemed like something I
could stomach as a friend.
I was interested.
I'm a skeptic naturally,
but I was like, OK.
Let's take a look.
So she sends me through
a 200 page PowerPoint.
And I opened it up, and
immediately, within seconds,
I see a clarity, a profundity,
a depth of purpose,
and I see what
Chelsea's talking about.
And I spend the entire night
translating the PowerPoint,
and I stopped everything
else that I was doing.
And that's why I'm here now.
And so in that period,
I've spent time
in Anji, China, a lot of
time with Ms. Cheng, who
has developed this approach.
I have worked as
her interpreter.
I've brought educators
from the United States
and Australia and Bangladesh
and Sub-Saharan Africa.
I brought them to Anji
to experience this.
And so today I'm going to
share my view as a parent,
because one of the really
lasting changes that Anji
Play has made in my
life personally--
and this is why I'm sticking
to this contextual, personal
introduction-- is it's
changed how I see my child.
And what I expect of
people that are going
to be taking care of her and how
they see her and how I see her
and how my wife
sees her is informed
by this engagement
with these ideas.
So my PowerPoint is going to be
about 1/10 as long as the one
that I interpreted
and translated.
If it has 1/100 of
the clarity and depth,
then I feel like this
will be worth it for you
guys to be here.
So I'm going to
start on that note,
and I'm going to
start with this.
It says, this is your
brain-- or this is my brain.
I want you guys to take a
minute to take out your Pixel 2
or open a Google
Doc, and I want you
to write down or recall
your deepest memory of play
as a child--
your deepest memory
of play as a child.
I want you to take a
minute-- the first thing that
comes to your mind.
Think about where
you were, what you
saw, what you smelled, who you
were with, what was going on.
And really think about it.
And why this is important will
become clear in a few minutes.
All right, I hope everybody has
a memory of play as a child.
So Anji, China-- this
place that is the cradle
of a shift in how we
think about children,
how we think about the role
of the teacher, the role
of the adult, the
role of society,
really, in supporting the
growth, the development,
the learning of the child.
I think of it as the
Mendocino County of Shanghai.
It's about a three-hour drive.
It's beautifully
forested in bamboo.
It produces white tea.
If you remember
"Crouching Tiger,
Hidden Dragon," it's where those
wire fighting scenes were shot.
It's mountainous,
and it's diverse.
You can see-- if
you could just go
straight southwest
from Shanghai,
it's a three-hour drive.
It's rural enough,
and it's originally
disconnected enough that it
has its own distinct culture--
its own distinct way of
being, way of living.
It's a really gorgeous,
pleasant place to be,
and I hope that all of
you will join us there,
because we do have
opportunities to come visit
and to see what's
happening there.
In 1999, Ms. Cheng is
appointed to the position
of director of pre-primary
education for Anji County.
In China, the way the
system works is you
have kindergarten, which
is for ages 3 to 6.
It's not compulsory.
It's optional.
It's not a mandated curriculum.
There are very broad
guidelines, and it's
provided on a need basis.
So tuition is calculated based
on the financial wherewithal
of the family.
So when Ms. Cheng comes
in to her position,
she comes from a background
of being an early educator,
of being a preschool teacher.
And when she was in college in
the '80s, when she was learning
her profession, a lot of
the focus was on traditional
abilities--
playing the piano,
drawing, singing--
approaches to
entertaining children.
And so she was put
in this position.
She was seen as somebody
who had great potential
for administration.
She moved over from
the side of teaching
to the side of administration,
and her first and most pressing
concern was access.
She had a large rural
county with a county seat
that was fairly urban, and she
knew that her responsibility
was to provide a clean,
safe, accessible space
for every child in her county.
And I'm not going to go into the
really long and detailed policy
story of how she
made this happen--
and it's brilliant, and
I'm happy to share that
with you if you're interested.
But she went from
a situation where
they had four sites that were in
the process of being privatized
at the beginning of
the 2000s when you had
a shift in economic realities
and the relationship
between the free market
and the government--
she made sure that
those schools stayed
part of her administration, and
then she grew it exponentially.
And so from 1999 to 2009, she
goes from 4 sites to 130 sites.
She goes from the
county seat to a point
where 98.5% of children
between the ages of 3 and 6
attend a public
kindergarten in Anji County.
So she started by building
the infrastructure.
So what is Anji Play?
We know where Anji is now.
We know how early
education happens--
to a degree-- in China.
First and foremost, it began as
a response to national policy.
So in 1989, the UN
passed the Convention
of the Rights of the Child.
In 1992, China ratifies that.
In 1996, China integrates
a very core concept
within the Convention, which
is that children have the right
to play.
They put it in their
guidelines, and then
in 2001, it becomes even
more firmly established
at the level of
national policy to say
that the primary activity
of the child in kindergarten
should be play.
But as I mentioned
a moment ago, there
is no mandated curriculum
for kindergartens in China.
There are guidelines--
very broad guidelines.
And so Ms. Cheng,
in her position--
in her position of
responsibility--
was confronted with this
question of, may kids play?
And so she had to
ask herself-- she
had to respond to this
question of what play is.
What is play?
And we asked that question
a moment ago to come back
to some of your memories.
And so as this is
taking shape, she's
asking herself what play is.
She's responding to
the concerns of parents
who, very reasonably,
want to know
that their children
are being taken care of
and that they're learning.
She is responding to a
crisis that she's seeing
develop amongst her teachers.
That crisis is something
that, in differing degrees,
exists in the United States.
It exists in your communities--
which is that increasingly,
the demands of primary
school are being pushed down
to the early educator.
And what happens then
is the early educator
is seen as a
caretaker, as a nanny,
as somebody who is failing
at teaching children what
they need to know.
And so you have the
status of the teacher
within the community as
one of passive obeyer
of the demands of the
parent and the demands
of the primary school,
and you have a question.
The teacher is saying, well,
what am I supposed to do?
What is my role?
I have all these
conflicting interests.
I know that I am a professional.
I know that I am somebody
that should be respected.
So one of the questions
that's being considered
and is being addressed as
this takes shape is, what
is the role of the teacher?
Who are they?
What are they
supposed to be doing?
There's also a response
to political imperatives
that's taking place
as this takes shape.
So I share this picture.
This is the party secretary
for a small village in Anji.
His name is Mr. [INAUDIBLE],,
and we've talked to him
and we visit him
every couple months.
What he describes is
he was taking part
in Ms. Cheng's drive
to build schools
where, at the local level,
local leaders were asking
the people in the villages to
provide land, to provide space,
to provide the
resources to create
these sites for children.
What he said, is he said, I was
able to convince the villagers
that they should give
the best part of land
in the center of our
village over to children,
because I knew that if their
kids were safe, that if they
were happy, that if they were
learning, they could go to work
and they could rest assured
that when they're at work,
they don't have to worry
about what's going on.
And my responsibility is to
the people in my community,
and so if we can do that
here, if we can do that
throughout the
county, then we're
serving a very important
political role.
So he saw his decision to
support early education
as a political decision--
as something that was
about sustainability,
about creating conditions
for prosperity,
for harmony, things
that are considered
top national priorities.
And I would assume that those
are top national priorities
in many countries.
There's also a response
to the status quo.
And this is a very
important frame
for looking at what's
taking place in Anji.
And that is that oftentimes,
when we design systems,
we first look at
what we're measuring.
We say, here are the outcomes.
And so the question
becomes, who decided
what those outcomes were,
and why are those outcomes
dictating our practices?
Why do you start
with product and then
move backwards to process?
And so what was very
fortunate about the situation
that this moment in Chinese
political and social history
provided was there
weren't any measures.
They were saying
kids should play.
They weren't saying,
you have to have
this rating scale or this
preparation for kindergarten.
And so they had the space
to discard those status quo
definitions of outcomes.
So this is what Anji
County Kindergarten
looked like before 2001.
Ms. Cheng calls this
the period of no play.
You can see why
she calls it that.
And I can tell you-- and
I've been to a lot of schools
in the United States that
change out the clothes,
change out what's going on the
walls, get some pedal desks.
You're going to find
situations in the United States
where children are being
managed, where they're
being contained, where
they're expected to sit,
where they're
expected to repeat,
where they're expected
to learn very specific--
irrelevant, in my mind,
to their experience
and to their depth and
complexity of knowledge.
So this is what was
happening pre-2001.
From 2001 to 2002, Ms.
Cheng takes this imperative
from the Ministry of Education
that children should play.
And so what do they do?
They build beautiful
environments, beautiful,
lifelike representations
of food, of various roles,
various spaces, kitchens.
And the teachers
design rules for play.
They organize the
children to play.
And at the same time,
they're winning awards.
At the provincial level,
people are saying, wow,
look at that
beautiful environment!
How did you get your
teachers to spend
all of their time creating this
beautiful space for children?
And Ms. Cheng walks
into these schools,
and I share this
picture not because you
can see the environments
that were created--
what Ms. Cheng said is
that children are not
smiling with their eyes.
This play does not
belong to these children.
And again, you change a little
bit about the environment.
You remove that Chinese
character in the background.
You can go to a lot of
programs in the United States--
programs that are
play-based, programs that are
child-centric, programs that
emphasize the value of playful
learning--
and those are the
expressions you see.
So false play was a reality
for Ms. Cheng in Anji,
and it's a reality for
us here as parents.
And if we go back to the
political imperatives,
us as citizens--
because we have to think about
what this is doing to children
and what that means in terms of
our relationship to children.
So what is true play?
And so this is the question
that Ms. Cheng asked herself.
She said, what is true play?
And where she started was
with her deepest memories
of play as a child.
She said, what do I remember?
What is it in my
childhood that is still
with me that I can't forget,
that when I think about it,
I smile?
That when I think about it,
I can smell those smells,
I can see those sites, I know
exactly how I was feeling?
And that's why I started
with that question,
because that's where she began.
She began with the sense of a
deep sense of responsibility
to children, to her
teachers, to her community.
And that began with a
question, and the question
that she started to ask her
teachers and her principals.
Because what she saw--
she saw teachers
and principals who
were spending days and
nights creating environments
that children didn't enjoy.
And so there was a tension.
There was a opposition.
I'm a teacher.
I'm trying to do things to
make you happy, to play.
You're not happy.
Something wrong
with you, there's
something wrong with me.
Everybody thinks that
they're not learning.
It became a very vicious
cycle of opposition,
and that's not what
education is about.
That's not what
learning is about.
That's certainly not
what play is about.
And so she reached
some conclusions.
And at the end of
our talk here today,
I want to ask you some
questions about your memories.
But she saw some common
characteristics in the memories
that she and her
principals and the parents
had about their own play.
Most importantly, the
play that was remembered
was play that arose from the
interest and the intention
of the child.
It was play that
was self-determined.
It was played where the child
decided with whom, where,
and what to play.
It was play that oftentimes
took place out of doors.
It was often risky play.
It often involved
extensive periods of time.
It was play that--
pardon me.
It was play where the outcomes,
in terms of the individual's
experience, were clear.
They had friendship.
They had bravery.
They discovered.
And so what they decided to
do and what they began to do,
was they decided they
needed to step back.
Ms. Cheng says that her
first instruction to teachers
is hands down, mouth
closed, ears and eyes open.
Now, that's not the end
point of the teacher,
but that's the starting point.
Because if you
cannot see true play,
if you cannot allow
for true play,
then you have no way
of knowing to do--
you have no idea
of how you should
act next, what you
should do next,
how you should respond to that.
And if we're saying that
this experience of true play
is the most fundamental,
the most natural,
the most complex
form of learning
that a child can engage in,
then that is the priority.
And so the priority is
to create the conditions
for that to happen.
Once you create the
conditions for that to happen,
then you can make decisions
about how to support that,
about how to allow children
to reflect and to share
and to express and
to build on that play
in order to create knowledge--
to create true, deep learning.
And in that process of
stepping back and observing,
if you tell the teacher-- or
if the teacher becomes aware--
that their role is not
to possess the authority
of knowledge, to transmit the
authority of that knowledge
to the child--
but that their stance
is a humble stance
of seeking to
understand the child,
they gain a deep
sense of expertise.
Because what they're
learning from is children.
Their expertise is
children, and what
their expertise in
children is is not
what some dead scholar
said 100 years ago
or 50 years ago or 20 years
ago or some live scholar said
5 years ago.
The knowledge that
they have of children--
the children that they're
seeing that are engaged
in the deepest, most
complex form of learning--
is coming from their
eyes and their ears.
And they're creating the
conditions for that to happen,
and so they become
experts in children.
And they can communicate
that expertise.
They can communicate that
expertise to children.
expertise to parents.
They can communicate that
expertise to primary school
teachers and policymakers.
And so what you see
when teachers step back,
when they're given that space,
that permission, when they're
empowered to allow children
to lead their own learning,
you see a status change
within community.
And that happened in Anji.
Teachers were no longer
nannies and caretakers.
They weren't passive
receivers of the knowledge
that they were supposed to pass
on from the primary schools.
And so the more
complexity they observed,
the more they
understood the child.
The more that they were
able to communicate that,
the more value that was
perceived around their work.
And so what we talk about--
and we talk about this,
and we'll get into
this in more detail,
because risk is an
important aspect of this--
is that all true
learning-- and what
they decided when they
stepped back in Anji--
was that all true
learning takes place
on the boundaries
of our capacity.
And if you don't step to the
boundary of your capacity,
you're not learning anything.
And some of you are engineers.
You have to problem solve.
You have to think about how
to do something differently.
You have to push yourself.
You're not sitting there
with instructions about what
you're supposed to do.
You're at your best operating on
the boundaries of your ability.
And so I want to bring us into
a quote here from Ms. Cheng.
And it's a little heady,
but you guys are smart.
And I could choose a quote
that's very touchy-feely,
and there are a lot of those
about how amazing the child is
and how our job is to
discover the child,
but I want to go right into
the heart of what this means.
So what she talks about is
returning the right of play
to children.
And that means the child's
play is self-determined.
It comes from their intention.
And she's not talking
about liberating children.
She's talking about
liberating teachers.
And that's important.
And as parents, we can think
of it as liberating adults,
because we are not bound by a
need to control or to direct.
And we're put in a position
of truly appreciating,
of deeply loving
children, because we
see their capability.
And we get that feedback of
children seeing our trust,
of feeling our trust,
of understanding
the respect that we feel for
their ability and knowledge.
And so that's a
liberating feeling.
It's liberating not
to be stuck in a back
and forth around
getting somebody
to do what they want to do.
And that's not to say that
as a parent, as a teacher,
there aren't instances
where we have to problem
solve around getting
somebody to do something.
But when you say that the
primary role of the teacher--
the primary activity
of the school--
is a respect and the
creation of conditions
for deep experiences
of true play,
you get this sense of
liberation, of empowerment.
And then we get into
liberating teachers
from formalisms
and utilitarianism.
And so utilitarianism
is just the idea
of outcomes defining
the approach--
of basing what you're
doing based on a perception
of what it will lead to.
And so that's assessing how
many letters you have it for.
That's how long you can
sit still without moving
and do your table work.
That's defining
learning narrowly,
based on measures
that don't account
for the incredible
depth and the complexity
of the thinking of the child.
So true play, as
it emerged in Anji,
was defined and continues to
be defined by five core values.
You can call them conditions.
And the first is love.
And love is many things,
but in its most pure form,
is stability and safety
and respect and trust.
It's that place that
you can stand on
and that you can go
and take that risk.
You can go and do
that thing that you
don't know the outcome
of, or that you think
you might know the outcome of.
But you've known this.
If you're playing and you run
away from home to go play,
you know your home is there.
There's that safe place
that you can return to.
And that's something
that teachers can provide
and that teachers get
back from children.
It's a deeply ecological
distribution of a condition.
So when teachers provide
that love of a deeply engaged
presence, of putting the child's
own experience and intention
on par with the most important--
or treating it as the most
important--
activity of the school,
children give that back.
Because when I, as a parent,
experience the capability
of my daughter in negotiating
risk and making discoveries,
I feel a deep sense of love.
I've given her love.
She's taken my trust
and my respect,
and she's shown me
what she's capable of.
And what happens then is you
can communicate that to parents.
You can communicate
that to administrators.
that to principals.
And it's not a one-way thing,
and it's not a simple thing.
But what it really allows for--
that deep sense of
safety and security,
that deep sense of belonging--
is it allows for risk.
And as we said, risk is
what learning is about.
Any real learning is testing
the edges of your ability.
It's standing on that
boundary and saying,
I'm going to put my foot over.
And we each experience
risk in a different way.
In Anji, there's an
incredible amount
of really impressive physical
risk that takes place.
But there's also social
risk, emotional risk.
There's intellectual risk.
Risk is not narrowly
defined as something
that might make you anxious
because it looks dangerous.
Risk is really about
taking that leap--
figuratively or literally.
And what you see
here in this image
is you see children
who have created
their own conditions for risk.
And there's a lot of research
on this subject that shows that
when children are allowed to
decide how and when to take
risks, when they're given
materials that they can master
and build, that they will take
risks that are developmentally
appropriate, and they
will-- for that reason--
be safer.
If you have a fixed
climbing structure,
a child can't decide its height.
They don't have a
knowledge of its structure.
They get bored of being
low, they go high,
and they fall off.
And they can hurt themselves.
But if you have children who
are building, who are testing,
who are experimenting, who are
using a minimally-structured,
large movable material to
build progressively over time
and they're given the space and
time to do that and they're not
being told, do this, do
that, take this risk,
take that risk--
because what's
important about risk
and what's important
about true play
is that can't come
from a teacher.
That can't come from an adult.
If you tell a child to jump off
of something, that is danger.
If a child builds something
and jumps off, that's risk.
And so there is a responsibility
to provide materials that
aren't going to break,
that aren't poisonous,
that spaces don't have pointy
objects sticking out of them.
There is a baseline of safety
that has to be provided.
But beyond that, by
creating materials--
and these materials, the
materials of Anji-- and there
are hundreds of materials
that Ms. Cheng has developed
over time based on her
observation of children
following specific principles.
They really create the
potential for maximum complexity
with minimal structure.
And so what's the
outcome of risk?
What's the outcome
of risk when you make
a breakthrough in your work?
When you do something and you
feel that thrill of jumping off
that ladder, when you
get up on the stage
and you give your speech and
you're actually doing OK at it,
you feel joy.
You feel a deep sense of joy.
And that's a reward mechanism.
And to me-- and I think that
there's a lot of science that
will back me up on this--
that if you're in
a position where
you have the sense of safety,
the stability of love,
when you're taking risks and
you feel joy, you're learning.
You're learning about yourself.
You're learning about the world.
You're learning about
all of the things
that we try to teach
in very dogmatic ways.
When you go back
to this picture,
there's physics going on there.
There's a lot of science
taking place there.
It wasn't set up for science.
We didn't demand that
they do this for science.
It wasn't designed for science.
But children are embodying--
with their bodies,
with the materials--
the materials, in a
way, are an extension.
They're an externalization of
what's happening internally.
They're a part of their
being and their body,
and so they are feeling.
They are experiencing.
They are building
these concepts.
And so that joy--
that joy makes you want
to take another risk.
It makes you realize that
risk was worth taking.
When you get love leading to
risk resulting in joy, what you
see is a deep, deep engagement.
You see children who spend hours
focused on solving problems,
on negotiating challenges--
socially or intellectually.
You see an engagement that is
the foundation for learning--
the foundation for learning
that takes place when they're 8,
or when they're 9,
and when they're being
taught abstract principles.
Not only are they
embodying these principles
that they're going
to learn later,
but they see the
experience of engagement
in understanding the
world as something that
has deep value and relevance.
The last principle--
the last condition--
is where we get to the role
of the adult in all this.
Reflection .
So when we went to
that memory and we
saw those memories of play where
there weren't adults present,
the difference that we have
is that we have schools.
And schools are systems, and
teachers have responsibilities.
And so how do you treat the
experience of deep engagement
and joyful learning as
a fundamental subject
matter for the children?
Well, what you do is you provide
opportunities for children
to reflect on their
own experiences.
And something funny happened.
When they first started
doing this in Anji,
the teachers were
so impressed by what
they were seeing
the children do,
they were so excited that they
were pulling out their phones
and taking pictures and
video, because they wanted
to show the other teachers.
Look what my kid did.
Can your kids do this?
And they realized that
they wanted to know
what the children were doing.
And so they began to provide
opportunities for children
to describe and to discuss
their specific experiences.
And so as the teacher
gains knowledge and becomes
more of an expert in the
children that are in their care
and in children in
general and children
in a context of
true play, they are
deeply attuned to what
those instances of learning
are-- what those
instances of insight are.
What are those moments when the
children are doing something
that they haven't done before?
When they're
encountering a problem
they haven't encountered before.
And so they have that
ability to take a picture,
to take a video
of those moments.
And so when the children
come back into the classroom,
they're invited to
engage in a discussion
of their own experiences.
And it's very open-ended.
It's not a leading discussion.
The children are really
leading their own description
of their own experience.
And what's crucial here is
the experiences that they're
describing are
experiences that have
come from their own intention.
These are things that are
deeply interesting to them,
because it's coming from them.
It's what they were just doing.
It's what they chose to do.
And so in the classroom,
that experience
is what is considered the source
of knowledge-- of learning.
That is the experience that
the children are being told--
that are being communicated
to through the decisions
of the teacher--
is what is most valuable.
And so what you see
is you see discussions
around problem solving.
You see complexity
in descriptions
of physical principles.
You see children
talking about the rules
that they have established.
You see children talking about
how they've solved conflict.
You have an opportunity
for children
to engage in thinking
about their own thinking.
They're engaging in
metacognitive reflection
around their own decisions--
around their own complex
decision making.
And as this takes
shape over time,
there's a decision that
there's a really important role
for children to take part
in art and description.
And there are broad guidelines.
There are guidelines
for early education,
and art is part of
those guidelines.
And so it's important, in the
school, that children have
access to materials for art.
They decided that
the children should
have an opportunity every day to
draw a story of their own play.
And that starts when they're
three, when they first
start in kindergarten, and
it continues all the way up
until they're six.
So every day, the child
is given an opportunity
without any other
prompt than to draw
or to depict the experience
of your own play.
And again, what you see
is you see an eagerness
to talk about what was
taking place-- again,
for that same reason that
that play came directly
from their own intentionality.
And what you see on the
back is you see writing.
And that writing is the
child's own description
of their drawing,
which is transcribed
by a teacher or a parent.
So if you think
about it, you have
14,000 kids that are doing
this on a daily basis in Anji.
Over the course of a
school year, that's
about 3.5 million play
stories created every year.
What you have is a
record of the learning
of the experience of
the child, and you see
a medium for shared knowledge--
for shared experience.
You see a medium for
sharing across schools.
And again, you see
documentation that
comes from the child,
that's put on the wall, that
becomes the primary expression
of the value of the school.
So not only does this practice
result in deep reflection,
problem solving, planning.
You see schematics.
You see the development
of narrative storylines.
You see these cells--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
One child starts doing
that, and all the children
start doing it.
You see a culture and
a language develop
from the child's own reckoning
with their experience
of learning.
So complexity-- I've been using
the word complexity a lot.
I haven't really given you
guys much basis for that claim.
So I want to share a
quote, and again, I--
Alison Gopnik, who is a very
brilliant, respected professor
at UC Berkeley, who is on
the cutting-edge of research
into cognitive
development-- she talks
about causal relationships--
causal mapping.
That our deepest thinking
is around cause and effect--
creating conditions and
reassessing those causes
and effects, making
inferences, and then planning.
And that's where
imagination and that's
where inference comes from.
So you see that
complexity that's
taking place in
environments where,
rather than a top-down model of
assessing specific skill sets
and learning outcomes,
you're saying the child
has a capacity for
deep complexity
and deep causal mapping.
And so where are we now,
and why are we here,
and what's going
on in our context?
And there's a debate that's
gone on for about 3,000 years--
at least in the west.
It's empiricism on one hand
and rationalism on the other.
And the empirical argument is
that we gain our knowledge--
our mind develops
from sensory input.
So experience informs
our knowledge.
If we don't experience it,
it's not part of our knowledge.
And what rationalism says
is that essentially, we're
born with little
acorns in our minds,
and they become oak trees.
And it's all there, and
it unravels over time.
And that has characterized, to
a great extent, our theories
of mind and our approaches
to understanding how we think
and how we develop.
And as we get into
the 20th century,
you move towards
an understanding
of behavior and development--
a scientific
description of why we
make decisions to
act certain ways,
and how we progress over
time developmentally.
And so in both instances,
there is deep truth to that.
If I give my daughter a cookie,
she'll get in the stroller.
That's behaviorism.
That works.
It's very limited.
It shouldn't be a strategy
for teaching or for respecting
the ability of the
child, but it's
present in how we think about
interactions with children.
And developmentalism,
which talks
about stages of development.
And it looks at
development as taking place
in a linear fashion.
It posits that the ideal
outcome is rationality--
is rational adult thought--
and that our role as
adults, or as teachers,
is to help children get from
one step to the next step,
to the next step, either in the
deepest or the most efficient
way.
And I like to sum
it up by saying,
we know what comes next.
We can predict what's
going to happen next,
and so we can help children get
from that one place to another.
And a lot has happened
since B. F. Skinner
and Piaget were around.
There's been a lot of new
thinking about education.
But this is a lineage
that still runs
very deep in how we
think about children
and how we educate children,
how we measure children,
and how we assess teachers.
And so what happens in the '80s
and '90s, what happens with
Alison Gopnik--
is there is a rethinking of
these ideas of rationalism,
of empiricism, of behaviorism,
of developmentalism.
There is idea that comes
forward called Theory theory.
And there's a elegant
simplicity to it
that I think speaks to what we
see happening in Anji Play--
what we see happening
in Anji, what we
see happening in
experiences of true play.
And the idea is that we're
born with an essential theory--
essentially, a sort of
scientific method that,
through inputs, we
can draw conclusions
about cause and effect.
And as we draw
those conclusions,
we refine our theories
and create new theories.
So in a sense, there
is an empirical aspect.
We're using these inputs
and our experience,
and there's a certain
rationalist aspect.
We have this essential
theory that we're born with.
But what that means is
that the more complexity,
the more opportunity you
have in terms of inputs.
The more space you're given
to create new theories,
to adjust your
theories, to engage
in that Bayesian adjustment
of predictions of outcomes
based on new inputs--
then you have, in the
period of development
between 0 and 6 or 0 and 8--
essentially, genius-like
thinking-- thinking that
isn't constrained by specific
naming of experiences.
And so there's a way in
which the work that's
happening at Google represents,
in a way, this paradigm shift.
I know that nobody here
is going to tell me
how the algorithm works,
but it's not a linear--
you get from here to there.
There is a consideration
of a variety of inputs,
of thinking about how
things are related,
and then decisions
made based on how that
works in a given situation based
on a universe of possibilities.
And so the danger that we have--
the great danger that we have--
is to say that that
is a deficient adult.
Your job's to get out of that,
because that's not thinking.
That's not learning.
Let's get those
numbers into you.
letters into you.
And particularly in
communities where
there has been a systematic
denial of opportunities
for play--
where policy, where capital
has decided that in order
to solve a deficit,
we're going to teach
you earlier and
faster and harder
and we're going to
measure you more.
And we're not only
going to measure you.
We're going to
measure the teachers,
because if you're not
learning your letters,
your teachers are failing.
We should take their money away.
There is a very vicious
and oppressive outcome
that is born from ignoring
this paradigmatic shift in how
we see the mind.
And that shift is just
now being embodied
in a very systematic
approach to education,
and that's what's
happening in Anji.
And that's why what
we're talking about
is a revolutionary,
epistemological, paradigmatic
shift away from teachers
as keepers of knowledge
to teachers as
creators of conditions
for deep, authentic
learning that receives
the respect that it deserves.
So we oftentimes talk about
Anji Play in a variety of terms.
It can be referred to, I
think, as a philosophy.
I think that's accurate--
a philosophy of education.
It can be referred to as
a complete, comprehensive
approach to early education.
In its totality, it consists
of materials, technologies,
practices, environments.
But the reason it
works, its DNA,
the reason it's different
from a top-down model
of defining outcomes that
every kid should have,
is because it's a
grassroots ecology that
is based on respect for
the child, for the family,
and for the teacher.
And so that ecology
connects all of these points
in a relationship that's defined
by those crucial elements
of learning and experience.
And we talk about
this in our work.
And my work, for the last
3 and 1/2 years, has been,
how do I share
this with integrity
with the world outside of China?
And that work includes
working with pilot partners
in the United States.
It includes talking to parents.
It includes talking
to educators.
And whenever we look
at what we're doing,
we look at these
five principles.
And if something doesn't
feel right, I say,
is there some issue
around the love?
Is somebody not
feeling love here?
Are we not on the same
page about our risk?
I will look at myself.
I say, why am I
not deeply engaged?
Am I not feeling a sense
of joy from what I'm doing?
And then maybe we haven't
been reflecting enough.
There is a way in which--
the definition of this ecology
is these five principles,
and it stretches
beyond a curriculum,
and it's what creates the
strength for it to take place.
It's what creates the
conditions for it to grow.
And it's why it can't
be easily boiled down
to a simple set of instructions.
It's not a boxed
binder of lesson plans.
It's about a fundamental
change in the stance
of the adult towards the child.
And so what you
see as this happens
is that you have support.
So as government officials
see joyous children,
as parents see
joyous children, they
become involved in the
work of the school--
in the work of the teacher.
There's a whole
description of how
the materials and
the environments
have taken shape
over time, and that
involves parents bringing in
their own experiences of play
as children--
of reflecting on
what they were doing
when they were kids, building
brick ovens for their children
in their schools.
So there's a way in which the
creation of this ecology--
this deep engagement around
the learning of the children--
allows for a virtuous
cycle of strengthening
where the more you
become a part of it,
the more you can bring into it.
And what we're seeing
now is that it's
impacting elementary education.
The elementary
schools in Anji are
getting children who
are deeply engaged
in the process of learning.
And so as a result,
the entire province--
Zhejiang Province-- has
eliminated academic instruction
and testing and assessment
in the first year
of primary school.
So there's a recognition
that something important is
taking place and that
it would be a shame--
it would be almost a crime--
to stop that from happening--
to cut it off too early.
So again, the role of
parents, vis-a-vis teachers--
I'm speaking to you
guys as a parent.
It's often seen as the
biggest challenge of schools
to communicate with parents.
And so that's why
part of the ecology
is the engagement and the
participation of the parent.
The parent's ability to
own the same expertise--
to feel the same expertise--
the teachers have.
And so there's,
again, strategies,
and there are vehicles for
that to take place within Anji.
And again, resources,
materials, environments--
the things that schools need--
the thing that
schools here need--
become more freely
available when
the people who make
decisions about them
have a deep belief and
engagement in what's
taking place.
So I want to just briefly touch
on the role of technology.
I want to give
everybody a chance
for questions and answers.
But technology is a really--
and, I mean, we're
standing here at Google.
You guys know what
technology is.
Technology-- there's
a lot of controversy
over what the role
of technology should
be in the lives of children.
And so when you go into
an Anji Play school,
you see teachers with
smartphones taking
video of children playing.
And what that
video is being used
for-- as we were discussing--
is sharing and reflection.
The children are seeing
their own experiences,
and they're having an
opportunity to describe them
and to reflect on them.
It engages children in
an active reconsideration
of their own learning.
But fundamentally,
technology is a tool
for respecting the
experience of the child.
Technology is not a passive
medium for delivering content
that's been developed
by adults-- again--
to derive those
outcomes by some advisor
who said that this is how you
can get kids to learn colors
faster.
Technology becomes a tool that
the adult has to document--
to value--
the learning of the child.
It's also a method for teachers
to develop, for administrators
to develop.
When you have a deep record
of children's experiences,
you have the basis
for engaged discussion
about what's taking place.
You have an opportunity to
understand the learning that's
taking place for children,
and you have the opportunity
to understand what
decisions about materials
and environments--
what impact that's
having on children.
And you see the ability
to share with parents.
That when parents see the
capacity of their child, when
they have an opportunity
to experience
the bravery, the
compassion, the ingenuity
of their own children-- again,
that's part of the ecology.
So insofar as technology
has a crucial role in Anji,
it has a role in supporting the
development of that ecology.
And for now, as we begin to
expand what's taking place
in Anji to sites in the United
States and in other parts
of the world, technology
allows us to communicate across
distance, to share in that
professional development--
that understanding,
that analysis--
with China, with Budapest,
with Madison, Wisconsin.
And so we can share
and we can talk about,
and we can think about
what's taking place.
And we can think about
what we're doing,
as adults, based on
what we're seeing,
and based on what
we're documenting.
And again, a natural development
of a practice, of a use,
from that starting point--
that humble place
of saying, there
is something that a child can
do that I have no idea about.
There is an ability,
there is a capacity
that I have no ability
to guess or predict.
And so what I have to do is I
have to seek to understand that
and to see that.
That's my role.
And so technology is a tool
that's come out of that.
Because once you see
that thing, you really
want to know what's going on.
And so obviously,
in Anji, that's
asking children
what they're doing.
It's letting children
draw that experience.
It's having them
talk to each other.
But as a teacher,
or as a parent,
it's the opportunity
to review that,
to think about that, to
document that, to keep that.
And again, it's an
acknowledgment of the fact
that technology exists,
that it's powerful,
that it's unavoidable.
I think it's a mistake
to say technology is bad.
Children shouldn't
be exposed to it.
And then go out in the world
and see technology everywhere.
So it acknowledges the
reality of technology,
and it uses it to crucially
respect and reflect the child's
experience and learning.
So a typical day in
an Anji Play school.
And I know we're
getting to the end,
and so I want to just zoom
through this really quickly.
But again, the primary
experience of learning
is open-ended,
self-determined play.
And that's given, usually,
at least two hours every day.
But it's a full-time
schedule, so there's a lot
of other things that happen.
There is the daily
contact that comes
when you drop off your child and
pick up your child at school.
There's outdoor play.
There's also indoor play.
There's time that's provided
for reflection, for expression,
for self-care.
The children are
encouraged to take the lead
in learning how to use the
bathroom, how to drink water,
how to take care
of themselves-- how
to do all of those
things that are
necessary for ownership
of one's own experience
and self-sufficiency.
There is a lot of
inquiry that takes place.
And what I call
extemporized pedagogy--
I think that there is a term
called emergent curriculum,
and in my understanding, it's a
little bit different than what
happens in Anji.
But it's really about creating
opportunities for children
to learn based on their
expressed interest.
And it's less like what we think
of as project-based learning,
because it's more immediately
responsive to what's happening.
And so the teachers
do play a role
in providing that support
for the children's interests.
So I think it's a mistake
to think of the teachers
as standing behind a glass
wall and letting children
do whatever they want.
The teacher has a role of
authority-- of respect--
that they create
routines, that they
are the people
that are protecting
the play of the child.
But they're teachers.
It's not a free-for-all.
It's not "Lord of the Flies."
It's expertise at it's
finest, really, in teaching.
And so what you have from
this is you have flexibility
so that teachers can decide
how aspects of the day
are organized based
on what they observe
in the interest of the teacher.
And again, that's a deep
respect for the teacher
in making decisions about
what is most important based
on their knowledge
of the children that
are in their care, and
protecting teacher time.
And so every Friday
is a half day,
and during that second
part of the day,
the teachers get
together and they
talk about what
they've seen that week.
They share their videos.
They talk to each other .
They meet both within the
school and between schools.
And that time for reflection--
that time for joyous engagement
in understanding the children--
becomes the basis
for their decisions
as teachers moving forward.
And again, regular opportunities
for parent engagement-- parents
are brought in to
take part in play,
to engage in documentation,
to engage in sessions where
the more experienced
parents lead them
in video analysis
of children's play.
So again, that part
of the ecology-- that
engagement with the parent,
the bringing the parent
into the experience
of the school.
And now we're
really bringing this
to programs in
the United States.
That's a really critical
aspect of our work--
is that as it scales in China,
as it scales beyond the 14,000
children in Anji
to 80,000 children,
now, throughout
Huzhou Municipality,
it's set, now, to expand
across Zhejiang Province
to all 90 counties.
And it's become a matter
of national importance
at the Ministry of
Education level--
that these
opportunities for play
are crucially important for
children in the United States.
And so what we're doing is
we're working with partners
that see the value of this--
that see the necessity of this
for their community.
And so we're really
focused on programs
that serve children that
have often been denied
these opportunities for play.
We've decided that to
create a model that
will allow us to scale
this with integrity,
with fidelity, with purpose,
that we have to begin working
with partners that don't have
huge budgets, that don't have
the access to every new
thing that comes up,
but with programs that
are deeply committed
to the importance and the
urgency of this experience
for their children and
for their communities.
And so right now, we've got
partners in Madison, Wisconsin.
We're doing this incredible
program with the Madison Public
Library, which is a free drop-in
program with the public parks
there.
With Sierra college, which is
in California, and Contra Costa
College in California, and
Wu Yee Children's Services
in San Francisco.
And it's growing.
We're getting incredible
interest from across the world.
This is a map that
represents the geography
of the people that
are contacting us
about the need for this
in their community.
So this is not something
that is limited
to a rural part of China or a
fancy play-based kindergarten
in Palo Alto.
This is something
that is crucially
important to children
throughout the world, because--
and this goes back to what we
were talking about before--
we don't know the
challenges that we're going
to be facing in 30 or 40 years.
And I don't think
we're particularly
prepared for those challenges.
And so if what we're
teaching is how
to confront the challenges
of 50 years ago,
then we're in a really
precarious position.
But if we say, provide the
optimal conditions for children
to understand the world and
themselves, to solve problems,
to work together, to
understand the world--
then I think that puts us in
a much better place 50 years
from now, 60 years from now.
And so it's
incredibly important.
And the people that really
understand the trajectory
of our societies--
that understand the trajectories
of the human minds--
recognize this.
And so you guys
are all here today
because you're early adopters,
because you saw something
that interested you.
And those early adopters are
parents, and they're teachers.
But they're also some
of the greatest minds
today thinking about education.
And so I want to end with
this quote, because it really
brings home the fact that
things are changing fast
and that what we
need for our children
is the ability to
understand themselves
and to confront what the
reality will be when we're gone.
And so that brings me back to--
I want to say thank you--
but it brings me back
to that first question
I asked, which
is your deepest memory of play.
And what I want to tell you is
that we're getting to a point
where children don't have
those memories of play anymore.
And so if I'm going to talk from
the perspective of a parent,
I have a sense of
responsibility that when
my daughter, who's 3 now,
is working at Google--
maybe she won't.
I don't know-- but
she's at a talk.
That when she's asked,
what is your deepest memory
of play as a child?
She doesn't draw a blank.
That she can speak
to that experience.
And my hope-- and that's what's
been part of my parenting--
is that she'll have too many
experiences to remember,
and that she'll have
to choose one of many.
And so I want you,
if you're parents,
to think about this when
you're with your child,
when you think about how
you schedule their time,
how you interact
with them around
play, what you expect of them.
Take a step back.
Put your hands down.
Close your mouth.
And see what you can see.
So I want to thank you guys
for taking the time to listen,
for taking the time
out of your day.
I had a video I wanted
to show of my daughter,
but we're getting really late.
And I'd love to provide
an opportunity for anyone
to ask questions
that might have them.
So the question is,
the cultural challenges
and the regulatory challenges
of bringing Anji Play to China.
The cultural challenges-- so the
name Anji is a county in China.
But what I would say is that
deep, authentic learning--
that true learning and true
engagement, the experience
of joy and of love--
really is, more or
less, universal.
In terms of acceptance--
I mean, I think
that's a question
of education and of sharing and
our work to share these ideas.
And it's also the work of
policymakers and scientists
that the most
advanced understanding
of cognitive development
is reflected in policy
around education and
around expectations.
So it's the work of
parents to demand this.
It's the work of policymakers
to understand this.
And it's the work of
all of us, really.
And it really
doesn't matter where
you happen to be culturally.
But I think that at
the end of the day,
it comes down to a commitment
to respect children.
And I certainly hope that's not
a culturally-specific value.
In terms of regulatory
issues, the science
around self-determined
risk is very compelling.
And the standards around
licensing for safety
are not based on that very
compelling, very, very
cutting-edge science.
So there's catchup
that has to take place.
At the same time, we
live in a democracy,
and we can make change,
and we can make demands.
And so oftentimes, when
we engage in change,
you hear a lot about why
things aren't possible.
This can't happen.
That can't happen.
That can happen.
We're working with
pilot sites that say,
we're going to make this happen.
They're figuring out
ways to make that happen.
So if you have the determination
to create the conditions
for what we're
describing, then you
can figure out how to
change those regulations,
how to work within
those regulations.
There's always a way--
in any context-- to figure
out, to problem solve.
Because what Anji
Play is largely about
is problem solving.
It's about problem solving.
It's about complex
problem solving.
It's about taking risks.
[INAUDIBLE] school system--
do you feel that you we need--
do we need a federal standard
to ensure that students
are learning effectively?
That is a big question.
I think that there is
a lot of fragmentation
around the organization and
policy around education.
We have states, and we have
the federal government.
A lot of that is tied
into funding mechanisms.
So there are
accountability measures
that are tied to how
schools are funded.
So it would be great if the
federal government wanted
to work with us to
create an assessment
of true play and true learning.
So if that were the case, I
would certainly support that.
I think that I would
absolutely, absolutely advocate
for more spending at
the local, at the state,
and at the federal
level in children,
because there's incredible
amounts of research
that that is a good
investment, that that pays off.
And so what we have
in Anji Play is
we have a very comprehensive,
clear, scalable model.
And so that can be the
basis for that change
on a national level.
It's the basis for the change
on a national level in China,
and I think our goal is that
it's the basis for change
around the world.
So we're going to have to work
with the federal government,
and I think they'll see how
effective that learning is,
and then they can create
some standards based on that.
Well, thank you
guys so much again.
I hope you'll check out
some of our resources
online and stay in touch.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]